я десятий 2 пропустіть зосима моно плівка
ми з брюссельської трибуни
європарламенту його куліш не голова
підкоп із презентуючи українським депутатам
створу ну за їх нею участь програму
реформування верховною радою розхвалю
народних прибраний мережу за і несе її вниз
мовляв у пірса за 25 іншим депутати
адже слив право форми вирішили ду з правою
український парламент поважають у брюсселі
грубим тягачи дане коло у парета червона
тільки по ременя з верховну раду і
папороть з іклами а джен і не за
сир і після євромайдану
вони ви мохом вони потреба мокре нс кого
існував розумний закону, що дав орган на
вид побачи, а на й не ті ти не
заплутати і в говорити підкоп зворот
їй big так що мало s2000 закон удавчик
initiate і в українських народних прибраних
сім'ї закону, що дав спамом
парламентарям шлюбу та політичної
культури та конструктивних дискусій
а штат верховної ради на те роздутий
кокс пробу але і з круті такі кицьки
мечеті у дупель шматки міністру
і створи ти універсальний механізм
чиновник скайпу кольоровості
єдиний шлях для україни вибір це гарніше
мій бот не створив це інституті і кіпру
чує чесно без кори слабке науки
реджина та кам'яний маніпулює
представник і власника бізнесу з
інституті великих протягнути коротші люди
проти добрий солодкий інституті
дають клубних проти коротше люди не здати
не тільки проти ти реформа верховної
раді травня сухуватий живопису адаптацій
узаконити до європейських норм про все
роботи свічки
сам список актив над 100 стурі ніг
сир від porsche червових закон ще дорівнює
мантую діянь з політичних партій то
вибіркову системи машини з нашими seo
заробіток щоб вас вибрав процес за
Крим закон про вибір це низько інших
законі в ідеальності політичних партій
то їх фінансування адже тоді ви магом
міжнародного законодавства
ми проводимо про консультацію ми з нашими
кола йому заради Європи це венеціанської
комісії у брецель їжу дають поважав його
на шию хваливати правою не закони, а його
кону вати їх c100 метушні пройдуся їм
беруть би швидкістю
депутатам знову нагадала в рази вигляді їх
неволі закласти будинок
безвізового режиму eco мої будні реформ
у лісі ми не можемо спливати на владу
україна суборенда країна місяць може
прохоп інакше паради і нехай спить ободною
прахова ти адресою арена краї на моїй
правій руці. хоча я кв провертати
ізопропанолу не тому коксом зміїний
українцям чи європейцям малюка накласти
ви вирішите уявіть брюсселя в кен
мало що вони оптимістично